here's the great thing about joe biden's
administration and what
what uh our political leaders decided to
do with printing all this money we might
all be millionaires soon yeah yes
look at that i can't wait you guys want
to see something crazy
oh that hyperinflation is let me let me
let me pull some up for you guys all
right check this out we got the you ever
see the us debt clock
yes i can't even look at it it's a real
time
let's check it out check this out tim
why are you doing this the
usdetclock.org says
savings per family 36 875 dollars
the the average savings per family so
that means grab a random family in new
york they got 36 thousand dollars in
their main account
that's a lot of money right that sounds
wrong but i don't know if that because
that used to be a lot of money
so but hold on that's the average
because don't they say like oh because
certain families have 100
600 it says or unseen expense so the
well it's the average not not the media
liquid cash in personal savings for all
u.s families divided by the number of
u.s families okay so there's a small
group of them that are
super rich and then everybody else uh i
i don't think there's enough rich people
to skew it that heavily
but it's probably like okay so maybe the
the the median for the
like middle class probably like 20k or
or whatever so uh but let me let me let
me jump over here
we have this button look at this button
right here it says debt clock time
machine oh no and i'm going to click
this and i'm going to jump to 2025.
let me ask you oh what do you think the
average savings per family will be
by 2025 107 170
based on the inflation we're seeing now
hundred and seven all right all right
all right answers what do you think
george
um sure from 108.
your price is right here
by taking the current the current
tracking and the current numbers
jumping four years from now says that if
you divide take the total number of
liquid cash in all savings and divide by
the number of families the average is
half a million dollars that's pretty bad
so and here's the thing oh but that's a
big number right that means
like i said we're all millionaires so
think about this wait wait that means
if one bitcoin right now costs thirty
six thousand dollars one bitcoin in 2025
will be worth half a million dollars
that's a lot of oh man in here that's a
lot of i'm gonna buy bitcoin well here's
here's the ceilings to buy for your
grandma
here's what's um excuse me here's what's
really scary about this so this is the
the projected numbers by 2025 but
i mean look back in 2016 no one no one
would have predicted that by 2021 we'd
be 28 trillion in debt so
it could be far worse by 2025. inflation
in
2016 the national debt was 19 trillion
19. yeah it was just under 20
27. and yeah now we're 28 28 dude
by 2025 the national debt is projected
to be
50 trillion which is good
that's fine that's fine everything's
okay well you can see how it manifests
512 000 savings per family what people
need to understand that means
right now what's happening somebody's
like i got 36k in the bank
why do i need to work i'm good so then
in order to get people to work
mcdonald's is offering a thousand dollar
sign-on bonus
in order to pay for that sign-on bonus
those increase wages they charge more
for burgers
it just makes everything cost more yeah
exactly so right now there's the bitcoin
conference going on have you guys seen
this yeah
i think max arizona is down there
someone yeah yeah he walks in everyone's
like
standing ovation and he was yelling and
he's like f elon or something like that
it was hilarious
and uh there's a big dumpster outside of
it that says tr uh cash is trash
and it's full of venezuelan you know
boulevard yes
or whatever so people were actually
making
paper art out of their venezuelan marks
and selling it online so they would make
like
bags and wallets and sell those on the
internet to get a higher return on their
money than they would have just
converting it to dollars
interesting so when you google it
it's uh uh what pops up is our good
friend
luke rodkowski oh he says there's free
venezuelan bolivars in a dumpster at the
bitcoin conference
that's not except they require energy to
acquire so nothing's free
i think you know i would take a bunch of
those as well
oh i'd be like bro i mean we're fighting
over toilet paper right now
like come on they're giving away for
free wood costs a lot yeah i think it's
made of plastic though
but either way it's like boxes and boxes
of boulevards just in a dumpster
you're the craziest thing is cause like
i've been to venezuela you we had a we
had a big black garbage bag
full of the money and i was like what's
the point dude just bring a ten dollar
bill from america to buy your pizza
otherwise i'm gonna hand some guy a
garbage bag thrown in his trunk
and eventually you're just like dude i
didn't want to carry it's not even worth
the carry yeah
fiat well they keep printing all this
money joe biden
is 22 trillion in borrowing six trillion
in spending
so what do you think is going to happen
to the economy what does that mean where
is he borrowing that from
and what's he where so he's he's issuing
another 22
million trillion borrow from the federal
reserve is that what this is i mean the
borrowing probably is bonds
and loans etc debts so it could be like
you know they pledge to pay something
and then track an invoice
but they're going to knock our debt from
28 trillion to 50 trillion with this
by the time joe biden leaves office
after his first term because you know
he will and donald trump has already
issued an email
where he said the next time i'm in
office we are gonna be
nearly double the national debt 50
trillion
that's amazing i remember when they were
like the debt ceiling and the
the national debt is too high and now
it's just like deficit spend deficit
spend until nothing is worth nothing and
everybody just you know
lives off of saltine crackers basically
yeah 50 trillion that's going to be
fantastic
well it just means look i think the
economy will keep on churning
but uh your savings is gone so if you
have us dollars right now this is why
people are buying uh
you know houses like crazy but i'll tell
you what man
uh so i got a message today from
the the uh jessica who does our graphic
design stuff [ __ ] she had a photo
i think it was starbucks and they were
like we're out of we're out of peaches
we're out of strawberries we're out of
fruit we're on a coffee we're out of
this right at that it was like a sign
they're like we don't got nothing
so they keep saying supply hasn't caught
up yet and i'm like
then why is the shortage why are the
shortages getting worse you know like
maybe joe biden keeps paying people not
to work and printing money like crazy
and uh
i don't know i'm looking for a silver
lining here you can i don't know why
okay buy silver well that's financial
advice i would never give
everyone just kidding friendly
suggestions don't buy silver that's not
what i said that's financial advice too
if i ask you for financial advice can
you give it to me as a friend
ran away even if you're not a finance
manager sheamus sheamus
is just chugging all of this while he's
like a gallon of water he's he's hot
look you guys i wasn't intending to give
financial advice
i didn't that's a silver lining
right now right now the average savings
for family 36k
price of bitcoin 36k coincidence maybe
but if inflation is is gonna track
savings bitcoin's gonna be at half a
million by 2025. i think it'll be higher
it'll be higher yeah because it's not
just not financial advice
because listen listen bitcoin tracking
just for inflation half a million
but add on the fact that it's going to
be more widespread yeah so at this
bitcoin conference it was crazy someone
posted a video where the line
was like blocks and blocks long to get
in bitcoin
is legit here man yeah elon musk can cry
as much you can cry all day and night
about it posters little silly memes
and nobody cares people were like
posting they were gonna sell off tesla
stock they don't want to be involved
because tesla is playing dirty games or
whatever
or because elon is but i think
if if it's tracking just for inflation
half a million for a bitcoin
you add in the fact that we got four
years of bitcoin growth
and you got development million dollars
two million dollars per bitcoin
and then people are going to wish they
had some that's not financial advice
no i don't don't buy don't no that's
financial i know
don't do anything just just don't listen
to me is that financial
don't listen to people to invest in
freedom tunes t-shirts
if i ask someone to buy something um i
think this is not financial advice but
if you want a freedom tunes t-shirt just
go to freedomtunesmerch.com and there's
a t-shirt oddly faster i think you're
allowed you're allowed to suggest them
to buy them but not to invest in them
it's not an investment all right now
here's the thing the money you have
might be worth less in the future and
you could have got a t-shirt out of it
but you won't be able to it'll be too
late so
freedomtunes.com uh or
freedomtunes.merch i'm sorry
freedomtunesmerch.com
financial advice i can't even get a
domain name right bro this is
freedomtunesmerch.com
this this bitcoin conference was lit
because like not only do they have the
venezuelan dollars in the dumpster
not only was it jam-packed with people
who are super enthusiastic about this
decentralized currency
but laura loomer confronted jack dorsey
and i'm i'm all here for you what's
there jack dorsey who's the jack dorsey
was speaking and she really
and she got up she got up and she's like
you're manipulating elections
and then i guess she got you know
security throughout or whatever but i'm
like
that's excellent so you've both taken
him to school
oh i mean laura has gone after everybody
she chained her
she handcuffed herself to the twitter
building in new york really yeah
yeah so that's you know i just yelled at
the guy i guess like i i argued with him
he had his bodyguard that was when tim
and i met i asked him to do a voice in
the cartoon i made about you yelling at
jack dorsey
yeah i was unaware of everything that
was being done
oh yeah we got we haven't discriminated
against conservatives if we want people
to be free on our platform
that's the only way and then who did the
voice of a vagina goddess
i think it was me yeah i didn't like i
couldn't do an impression of her so i
just did like a generic bad female voice
i was like well actually
that we have to the reason the website
did this but i i was more i mean the
jack
the truth is to just make sure all
conservatives
can rot in hell i just the only way
people are free to speak is if
conservatives can't talk it's just the
only
possible solution no i think they
genuinely believe that
a run-of-the-mill conservative is like
you know when they when they imagine a
regular conservative
it's like a liberal like ezra klein
that's how they see conservatives well
i'm gonna i'm gonna take a line from
michael knowles here but
as he says uh or to put it in his words
the only thing conservatives have been
able to agree on since the cold war is
to cut taxes
and so i think to many people on the
left like that's just what conservatism
is like conservatives when you call it
like talk about tax cuts but everything
else is just that's
weird alt-right what something what is
right-wing anymore
yeah dude nazis were right-wing i heard
wild you know psychoactive experience of
reality it's not right-wing at all
that's one of the least right-wing
things i've ever heard in my life that's
what i'm talking about tim castillo's a
far-right podcast
hosted by a liberal and some weird
hippie guy as soon as i'm off air ian's
like telling me i need to like read
aquinas and
people don't realize it's a wig is it
well that's actually crazy too man's got
a very
short haircut it's funny that that's
also considered right wing now like it's
just it's
it's just strange how all like the
foundational philosophy of our culture
is
scary and dangerous i would suppose
jesus was probably left-wing
would have been considered left-wing for
his time like he was he was a radical
anti-establishment you know he spoke out
against the empire
so real quick yeah speaking out against
the empire what do you think
and the caps are they're not left-wing
yeah
like the bitcoin conference is loaded
with libertarians the left and the right
thing
exactly well here's the thing and this
is why we have to be very careful
everything real quick sorry sorry just
yeah sure left literally means evil
that's all you need to know
yeah basically no that's that's what i'm
trying to say but no i mean kind of
because here's the thing we view
everything as left verse right when it
comes to our social structures right now
but these were not terms that were used
prior to the french revolution
and so you kind of have to stop trying
to put different
moments in history into those boxes i
know that the left
literally exists and existed from the
very beginning to counter
the catholic church in its goals if you
look at the french revolutions what they
did
yeah yeah if you look at the french
revolution and the foundational thinkers
of it and the foundational thinkers of
leftism their entire purpose has always
been to counter
christian values and more specifically
the catholic church and its goals i got
i got
i was wrong it doesn't mean evil okay i
looked at it i just we have uh
adam online etymology left means
opposite of right from old english lift
which means weak and foolish
oh my gosh i'm not i'm not kidding and
also uh the dutch dialect loofe meaning
weak and worthless
wow and sinister and also if someone
goes away they left
yeah there you go odd that's all bad at
such a nice they say the usual old
english
win stray straw left left hand
literally friendlier a euphemism used
superstitiously to avoid invoking the
unlucky forces connected
with the left side compare sinister
and there you go i would suggest we
don't put ourselves in the same position
that the french revolutionaries
found themselves in dividing people into
a left and a right
dude sinister literally means to the
left yes it does
it means contrary false unfavorable to
the left in the word sin
well i could have told you yeah and the
right literally means
right correct you are right that's
busted
so saying someone is far right you're
saying like you are very correct you're
very correct you're very correct
i agree with you very much no i disagree
with you because you're right i'm wrong
incorrect
that's that's all you got to say from
now on people are like you know you're
far right be like thank you i am correct
i am i am very right in all of my
opinions like they are correct they are
right and you're wrong there's so many
like common words like
right left wrong uh right
light heavy dark light
like this word the word light and the
word right have so many there's so
such simple proliferative words in our
language but have
vastly different meanings yeah depending
on how you're using it
i don't like it it's not enough words we
need different words for those
just make stuff yeah looking up the
origin of light and it's not related
light dark or it also means light not
heavy i don't know
it comes from loot light brightness
this is the word light that's it special
light means right
there you go light makes right well
no i don't i don't like that direction
you're going in ian all right thanks
pull me back from the edge i saw him
buying a pack of skittles earlier
should we i think humans really prefer
light because we're so visually oriented
i think
definitely well it was because darkness
was like night time was scary yeah you
know there's like bears and stuff you're
like sleeping
and you're like you know mind your own
business and like a bear comes out and
like bites you we really are
in this goes back to what we were
talking about earlier like the americans
being born here such a
like a just valuable in and of itself
and i was thinking just talking earlier
today about how it's kind of like being
in the the king's court like as
americans if the if the earth was a
kingdom we were the ones that were born
in in our living court drama
right now this is all that's going on
inside the castle it's really well let's
be let's be real like
you know ian when we were about to when
we were choosing our characters for the
simulation like we all chose easy mode
basically we were like let's put on
casual you know american and ian chose
white male 1
just absolutely determine what's our
best ending i'm just going to
eat it help as many people as i can beat
it then maybe i'll
i'll try it on hard mode late next time
yeah and hard mode would be what being
born like somalia
and today it would be yeah yeah or you'd
be born in like the middle of australia
i guess to like a witch doctor family of
like weird
european settlers who found themselves
in the middle of the
outback and you're fighting scorpions
and kangaroos at the same time and
kangaroos that throw scorpions at you
they carry them in their pouches
the worst and then once you like
once you get close enough to the cities
the kangaroos are now like pink they're
like the same animations but they're 10
times stronger
because the simulation didn't feel like
making new monsters yeah
that's just the reality of it elite
kangaroos
they're purple if you guys see the video
where the kangaroos at the guy's window
like banging trying to dude yes
that's terrifying it's all riffs this is
why australians need
guns there you go don't know why they
got room can you imagine a kangaroo just
banging on your door i don't know what
i'd do
if i didn't have my weapons aren't like
i'm sorry i'm not gonna do a fist fight
with a kangaroo nope
have you ever been friends with
kangaroos i thought like in australia
like kangaroos are like people you know
i don't think i watched a video where
they were okay australia went to war
with emus didn't they
in laws what they did no one can beat
them
what happened i need to double check
this i saw a video where like people had
a barbecue and a kangaroo just like
jumps in and everyone's like hey mate
and kangas is like doing this thing or
something
awesome it's like bouncing around yes
yeah they so so
they're not that nice to animals
australia did go to war with emus and
they did lose they did lose the world
they were just passed all across
australia fun fact you learn something
new every day
what is an emo i'm pretty anti-war but i
might be able to get behind the emu war
unfortunately they did lose though it
was funny when uh sydney watson was here
and she told ian about drop bears
yeah and it was all like whoa but they
were fake yes there's no drop she took
me for a ride what did she
what was she saying drop bears were so
like it's a joke that australians have
to trick non-australians where they
claim that koala bears will like
drop from the trees and land on you and
like maul you or something
drop bears i'm not a position to deny or
i believe it right
so they have like big onion rings i'm
not gonna like question the lived
experience of someone who's come to my
country from a foreign house and fosters
beer
that's a good question is it like
cultural appropriation uh foster is yes
i think
isn't in australia though i think right
yeah not there it's australian for beer
but it's not australian it's like the
irish people get angry at guinness
which is too bad because that's a great
beer yeah here's the here's the secret
y'all have never had a real goodness
unless you've actually yeah the guinness
that's in ireland is different when they
ship it over it actually messes with the
consistency i had one in dublin
yeah they do the there you go that's the
real one they do
legit you know guinness gives out only
to the people in ireland the history of
guinness
is pretty interesting the the irish dock
workers didn't have any money they were
making beer and then they'd sell
all the beer would be gone and at the
bottom of the barrel there'd be this
dark sludge and they didn't have any
money so they just started making beer
out of the sludge
of course we'll drink it it's alcohol
it's like at the bottom yeah of course
we'll try it it became one of the most
delicious
you know beer in my opinion on the
planet i love that our contribution was
the bottom of the bag that's a racist
racist stereotype
british people actually drink more per
capita than irish people do
is that true yeah i was reading about it
it's the guilt and the show the irish
drunk emerged because
this is what i heard it could be false
that when i irish immigrants were coming
to the united states like in the early
1900s and like late 1800s
they would pretend to be drunk if they
were homeless so they can get a free
night's sleep in the in the local jail
oh i know that i know that they're
called paddy wagons because irish people
were disproportionately arrested but
i don't know about that they're like i
was pretending of course i was just
pretending so i could go off to jail for
the night i had
why did somewhere were to sleep people
don't have snacks i'm totally
just presentings have had too much
alcohol in
my system right now people do it now
though people
people like homeless people will will
commit a low-level crime to get a free
place to stay that's so sad
yeah so sad you occasionally get people
that claim that they're uh
i can't make this joke i was gonna say
they complain that they can't breathe in
order to get taken to the hospital
instead of the jail it's not really it's
not a joke that's the worst part
yeah oh yeah people feign medical
illness when they're being arrested so
they get taken
often that was that was testimony a lot
oh all right
so then that makes it just harder to
deal with everything and then you get
young people who don't understand how
the world works and they're like burning
down
and then they literally go and burn it
down and they forgot the name of the guy
they were fighting for
they were fighting for a guy named sony
as they walk out with a 50-inch flat
screen under their arm
yeah there was there was looting and
fires the other day
in minneapolis in the no-go zone and
around it after they put it back
up yeah it was after they shot a guy the
marshals killed a fugitive
and so they were like let's go riot and
then unicorn right this lefty group like
interviewed a guy and he's like i'll be
honest i don't even know the na guy's
name i can't remember
and they're like his name was like
winston i think or something yeah i
can't remember his name
but then he was like i don't even know
his name and like you're you're torching
stuff in the street like don't you think
it's kind of important you know
the joke i made was like could you
imagine if you showed up for like a
business meeting you're like i'm on the
50th floor for a business meeting and
who are you meeting
i don't know no idea like sir you can't
come in
like you're not here for any particular
reason that's the nature of activism
these days though guys
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time